la fuerza bruta nunca vencerá a la
verdad con estas palabras el parlamento
europeo concedió este jueves el premio
sajarov a la oposición bielorrusa
representada por el consejo de
coordinación para volcar y vinci tory
del premio a los ganadores del premio
sigan siendo fuertes y continúen
luchando y luchando sepan que estamos
con ustedes el voz propia este consejo
de coordinación es encabezado por
tsvetana tica no busca ya actualmente
exiliada y lituania en radio o tweets
estoy muy contenta de que hayamos
recibido tal premio porque no es mi
recompensa personal es una recompensa
para el pueblo bielorruso me is what of
other songs teaford el premio llega en
un momento clave para este movimiento
en efecto tica no busca ya ha dado al
jefe de estado hasta el 25 de octubre
para que dimita amenazado con convocar
una huelga general
alexander lukachenko también está
presionado por sanciones de la unión
europea que ya ha tomado medidas contra
40 funcionarios del régimen
acusados de participar en la represión y
en el presunto amaño de las elecciones
cuyo resultado no reconoce la unión
todos los domingos decenas de miles de
bielorusos a pesar del riesgo de ser
arrestados y ahora de la amenaza de
municiones reales manifiestan en minsk y
otras ciudades exigiendo la dimisión de
lukashenko casi todas las personalidades
vinculadas al consejo de coordinación
han sido encarceladas puestas bajo
arresto domiciliario u obligadas a huir
al extranjero el premio ha servido
varias veces como antesala del premio
nobel de la paz y justamente el trío de
mujeres que hicieran campaña contra el
presidente también han sido nominadas
para la edición 2021